c'est un sujet qui a provoqué de
nombreux remous sur la précédente
mandature en avril 2015 le centre
nautique de maurepas reste porte close
son état d'usure et mis en avant pour
justification un site sportif qui
accueillait 170 mille utilisateurs par
an dont 40 mille scolaires des communes
de maurepas et l'encours et coignières
après de nombreux recours fait par
l'opposition le contrat de délégation de
service public a été signé le 6 janvier
2020 le projet doit sortir de terre en
une zone d'activités bientôt aussi zones
d'habitat paris ouest à cheval sur more
by coignières va progressivement changer
de visage
un écoquartier de 800 logements
continuent de voir le jour
la première pierre du projet a été
symboliquement déposée en avril 2018 où
les vertes central des places de
stationnement matériaux biosourcés ou
encore domotique dans les logements
la résidence de maricourt doit être
livré fin 2020 le projet complet devrait
lui prendre fin à l'horizon 2030 des
constructions pour augmenter le taux de
logements sociaux mort pas en compte
actuellement 17 5%
la loi oblige les communes en avoir 25 %
un bétonnage présenté comme trop
importants par l'opposition
autre enjeu qui concerne plusieurs
communes le carrefour de la malle me
donne attendu pour 2026 le réaménagement
du site prévoit son enfouissement la
verrière maurepas et coignières
actuellement séparés par la nationale 10
seront ainsi rollier